Morgen lieber guten Morgen Tim.
Na ja das tolle neue soziale Netzwerk.
Ich habe was viel besseres das hier das Tim ist das Internet.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 249 Jahr vom 9. April.
2018 direkt aus der Mittelebene nach stundenlanger Vorbereitung.
Der Verein wenn man nebenbei noch eine andere Sendung planen.
Genau.
Ich sitze seit heute morgen weil es ist ja möglich.
Warum drei eingefallen.
Ja mit Tagesordnungspunkt Tagesordnungspunkt wir wollen eine Sendung machen mit euch an.
Genau genau am 26.Mai 2018 in Berlin im Babylon.
Nichts nichts nichts weniger theatralisches und biblisches als gleich Babylon wir uns eingefallen.
Wer das nicht kennt ist eine ganz tolle Veranstaltungslocation,
vielen Rieger Weise primär als Kino bekannt obwohl es nicht im eigentlichen Sinne im Kino ist dann ist es eigentlich Theater es wird aber auch als Kino verwendet also dort Kinovorführung Stadt,
aber eben auch manchmal andere versagen,
und ja wir sind übereingekommen mit dem Babylon dort am 26.Mai die Öffentlichkeit zu bespielen damit seid natürlich ihr gemeint sprich nach unserer großen Gala im November 2016.
Jetzt Desigual.
Und ja mal so ein bisschen durchgezählt und eigentlich hatten wir ja gedacht vielleicht wir die 250 das richtige aber.
Das hat alles nicht so richtig zusammengepasst also wenn wir die Nummer 256 gemeinsam mit euch zelebrieren und ja.
Was kann ich kann man denn darüber sagen.
Ja wer also wer man kann sie ja die Aufzeichnung die Videoaufzeichnung von der LMP2 100 anschauen.
Wenn man so ein großes Gefühl dafür bekommen möchte denn diesmal mehr Platz letztes Mal waren wir im Stummfilm Stummfilmkino Delphi mit 300 Plätzen oder so.
Fiona ja.
Okay dann wären wir jetzt diesmal nur 100 Plätze mehr haben 100.
Ja so Gruppen 20 30% mehr.
Was er bis jetzt schon gesichert haben ist auf jeden Fall die live Zeichnung wieder das Feuer in die so sehr viel besser als wie er sich das Feedback durchgelesen hat.
Wenn es langweilig wird langweilig mit auf der Bühne bitte immer noch nach oben starren.
Roland wird wieder live zeichnet schönes großes buntes Bild wachsendes wählt mehrere Gäste die wir alle noch nicht hatten.
Bis jetzt nur Leute eingeladen die wir noch nicht alle hatten noch nicht alle haben auch noch nicht zugesagt deswegen sagen wir noch nicht aber sie auf jeden Fall toll und mehrere.
Vorprogramm.
Werden sind wir noch in der in der in der Planung das wäre wenn wir Vorprogramm in Klammern angefragt.
Genau also ansonsten können wir jetzt einfach so sagen noch soviel garnicht sagen aber ihr könntet euch ja vielleicht wenn ihr Interesse habt zu kommen den.
Termin schon mal freihalten 26.Mai saß noch mal wir werden auch in knapp zwei Wochen.
Dann hoffentlich den ticket sale online haben und dann kannst du es gehen.
Ticket sale startet exakt einen Monat vorher.
Also am 26 April.
Damit ihr euch das einfacher merken könnt an 26 April starte den Vorverkauf am 26.Mai ist die Veranstaltung in Berlin.
Anderen Samstag das heißt ihr könnt wenn ihr nicht in Berlin wohnt auch anreisen eines Dach abreißen.
Perfekt einfach.
An alles gedacht.
Logan rollstuhlfahrerplätze auch sowas gibt's.
Wird es natürlich geben.
Bevor die Frage kommt ist alles entsprechend geeignet dort.
Ja lass dich überraschen wir werden dann so in den nächsten Folgen die ein oder andere Bohne dann noch mal fallen lassen so sich die Beweislage erhärtet.
Und wenn ich unglücklich merkt euch den 26.04 Vorverkauf.
Oder 26.05 Veranstaltung Schulz aus.
Veranstaltung mp28 feingemacht.
Ja voraussichtlich nicht ankündigen wenn wir dich auf Handschaltung 5 Xbox.
Nehme ein Tag vor unserer Veranstaltung tritt ja die datenschutzgrundverordnung in Kraft und wenn wir da wäre es also damit wir die Veranstaltung derjenige.
Stimmt weil alle alle die schon mal in Facebook was eingegeben haben werden dann dem Untersuchungsrichter vorgeführt.
Schön wärs.
Nein nein nein also ihr werdet ja sicherlich schon davon gehört haben wir haben das ja auch,
zweimal bisher glaube ich im Fokus gehabt einmal als wir.
Die ganzen Hintergründe um Cambridge analytica mal auf gearbeitet haben bis hin zu den psychologischen und letzte Sendung letzte Sendung.
Bitte deine Hermes noch mal angestellt.
Genau weiß ja wie lange.
Letzte Sendung wurde das auf einmal zum Skandal und weißt du was ich echt ich habe da noch mal so drüber nachher auch noch mal die Artikel gelesen so gedacht da ist nichts Neues.
Da steht nichts neues drin also seitdem wir das damals behandelt haben und ich habe mich auch noch gut daran erinnert es waren ja als diese Anhörung zu den socialbot zwar im Bundestag ne.
2017 wo ich da irgendwie zu zwei Anhörung waren und auch bei einer so,
wirklich ein bisschen schlechter gelaunt ja da habe ich dann auch noch gesagt für das Problem ist nicht so scheppert das Problem,
soziale Netzwerke zielgerichtete Werbung Cambridge analytica Erde habe ich da eben und die habe ich alle angeguckt zu weißt aber ganz schön unfreundlich hier und,
da wackelt viele waren ja relativ viele Sachverständige und da.
Das war dann so der Moment wo mir langsam die die die Nerven reichen für dem Thema und jetzt anderthalb Jahre schon ein Jahr später,
Konfetti so ein bisschen,
Avantgarde des Nachrichten Flusses behandelt wurde ist ja doch einiges passiert.
Ja jetzt eher hatten sich so ein paar Fakten oder bleibt es auch einfach die Wahrnehmung im Kontext der Behandlung wie das Ganze in USA herumgereicht wird auch,
hat sich geändert das ist die Wahrnehmung in USA dieses Falls,
ist natürlich extrem geprägt von der vorgehenden Untersuchung der Zusammenhänge mit der Wahl 2016 also das was uns den Trump eingebrockt hat und,
irgendwie ist es auf jeden Fall Facebook nicht so richtig gelungen den Deckel auf dieser ganzen Geschichte zu halten weil sie sich natürlich auch wie immer eigentlich schon nicht so richtig geschickt anstellen dabei.
Wo sind wir jetzt jetzt dreht sich also eigentlich alles im Wesentlichen um die Frage.
Wie viele Daten sind denn jetzt hier tatsächlich geschlossen und.
Lasse den Eindruck in den USA wird das erste Mal das Thema Datenschutz überhaupt ernsthaft diskutiert also jetzt gibt es irgendwie ein Fall.
Andi.
Das was ja sagen wir mal so die Datenschutz Fraktion über die Jahrzehnte immer schon gesagt hat wo das jetzt auf einmal greifbar wird natürlich erst nachdem das Kind in den Brunnen gefallen ist und.
Ja neueste nachricht in der oder die erste neue und neuere Nachricht hat die mir letzte mal drüber gesprochen haben dreht sich dann auch erstmal um.
Diese Zählerei rund um die Anzahl der Profile die denn nun von Cambridge analytica tatsächlich als Basis.
Verwendet worden ist dazu muss man gleich sagen.
So richtig genau wissen, das eigentlich gar nicht aber das ganze wurde ja ausgelöst durch diese App.
Wo so eine hübsche Professor warst glaube ich.
Die Leute zu ihrem digital Leben befragt hat und dann konnte sich da rein optieren in diese App Design fleißig herum gesucht hat und quasi als Belohnung für die datenpreisgabe dann so eine Zusammenstellung,
die Vater hatte ich.
Epic fight for Fernseher.
Ja ich meine mich auch irgendwie noch dran erinnern zu können als das mal rum ging ja ich bin natürlich dran beteiligt aber hatte hatte das ohne immer so mitbekommt und damals war das ja auch noch so eine Phase,
wo seine ungeteilte Begeisterung für dieses ganze digitale Leben vorherrschte was ist auch noch so eine Erinnerung.
Hallo Bruder irgendwie alles mächtig zelebriert das dass man jetzt irgendwie sein Leben digital veröffentlicht und haben uns alle lieb und Pipapo und da spielt er das natürlich irgendwie vom Termin her wunderbar gut rein,
Referat ist auf jeden Fall noch mal nachgerechnet genauer wie viele Profile denn hier tatsächlich eingewilligt haben und vor allem und das ist nämlich der entscheidende Faktor an der Stelle,
wie viele.
Freundinnen diese Profile gehabt haben zu dem Zeitpunkt denn die Datenschutz Einstellungen nicht vorhanden Datenschutzeinstellungen,
spricht die Möglichkeiten über das Abi von Facebook habe ich den Apps damals erlaubt eben nicht nur die Profilinformationen der Leute die eingewilligt haben soeben auch automatisch die der,
Freunde mit abzugreifen was für sich genommen ja schon mal ein Skandal ist.
Und kam jetzt irgendwie auf die Zahl von 87 Millionen Betroffenen Profilen up from 50 Millionen Betroffenen Profilen mach dir für meinen Geschmack jetzt keinen nennenswerten,
unterschied aus bewegt sich ja mehr oder weniger immer noch alles in derselben Dimension.
Darunter wohl angeblich so an die 300.000 deutsche Profile obwohl da wohl nur 60.
Deutsche teilgenommen haben also relativ weniger.
Eskaliert sich ja hoch also dadurch dass die Freunde haben.
Auszeit einfach da merkt man mal wieder wie schnell hier die Zahlen anwachsen können.
Wir sind 80 Millionen halt niemand so richtig schockt außer dass es halt interessant ist dass Facebook seine eigenen Aussagen revidieren muss.
Matthias auch noch so nebenbei naja aber was mal genau nimmt wissen halt überhaupt nicht genau was eigentlich passiert ist denn in dieser Phase bis 2014 als siap eben diese Funktion vorgesehen hat hätten hat potenziell eigentlich auch alle Profile abgegriffen werden können,
von irgendwelchen Apps denn wenn die diese Daten erstmal haben.
Weiß man ja nicht wohin gehen ist ja nicht so dass die dann diese Information bei Facebook abspeichern und Facebook den anderen einfach zu drehen kann Soldaten sind hat gewonnen runtergeladen,
Zeit verwertet worden und wir wissen auch das Jahr der ganze datenmarkt der umtriebig ist und das Leben,
halbwegs scharfe Profilinformationen immer sehr begehrt sind spricht man kann eigentlich aus vielen vielen Quellen sich solche,
Daten eben holen korrelieren über E-Mail Adressen Telefonnummern oder andere Merkmale neuer und wo kommt man dann eben auch schon auf eine ganze Menge mehr Informationen nur da halt diese Profil Informationen von Facebook ebenso umfangreich sind und so viel,
über die User sagen mehr als jetzt eben nur eine E-Mail-Adresse sagen kann.
Heute am 9. April soll angeblich auch eine Benachrichtigung durchgeführt werden der User die in dem Fall da betroffen waren,
das können wir zum Zeitpunkt der Aufzeichnung der Sendung ist ja noch früh, ja nicht noch nicht so sehr viel drüber sagen der 9. April beginnt in USA auch etwas später.
Ja das müssen wir mal abwarten was das bringt natürlich ist diese Mitteilung sicherlich irgendwie peinlich und kommt auch viel zu spät ja also hier,
hätte sollen wir mal zum Zeitpunkt des in Kraft und danach nach dem Zeitpunkt des Inkrafttretens ist der datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Wir allein das schon ein Grund Facebook mit extrem hohen Strafen zu belegen.
Weil sie einfach nicht zeitgerecht eine Benachrichtigung durchgeführt haben.
Aber dieses Gesetz hat ja noch keine Gültigkeit von daher kann eine solche Strafe derzeit nicht vorgenommen werden aber das zeigt natürlich allen einschließlich Facebook.
Wie viel Musik eigentlich in den ganzen Datenschutz Spielchen jetzt drin ist ja.
Also seid auch noch mal so ein bisschen Hintergrund warum denn das eigentlich überhaupt so war also warum wurde denn überhaupt so viele Daten da bereitgestellt.
Ich muss zugeben ich bin kein kein Facebook Installer aber es war halt relativ klar damals war ja.
Dieses ganze Thema Apps auf Facebook irgendwie ein viel größeres Ding heute sind das eher kleinere Anwendung.
Und komme auch gleich noch mal dazu die werden auch potentiell jetzt nicht weiter anwachsen.
Aber wir hören uns Farmville das war ja noch so richtige Startup Dinger da haben alle irgendwie da ihre Schäfchen gezüchtet auf Facebook.
Und ihre Pflanzen gegossen und großen Spaß gehabt und so ist ja auch ein alles in Ordnung soll ja seinen Spaß haben sodass halt im Rahmen dessen,
eben auch sehr viele Daten weitergeleitet wurden denn,
Facebook Wahrheit dann der Meinung wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen in Reaktion auf den Erfolg der App Stores generell speziell natürlich der von Apple.
Dass das unter Umständen eben ein Business für sie ist das Facebook quasi als App platform riskieren könnte und dort mittelfristig und langfristig.
4profit immer kam hat sich nicht so richtig erfüllt ich weiß nicht genau warum.
Am Ende mal mögen auch genau solche Aspekte zum es im Ansatz schonmal eine Rolle gespielt haben also Privatsphäre Datenschutz sitze auf wenn Facebook das ja bisher nicht so sehr.
Nicht so sehr von Dingen abgehalten hat aber fahren wir das dann irgendwann auch umgekippt und andere Dinge,
war jetzt nicht so populär wie die App sie dir direkt auf die Mobiltelefone kamt,
zu Maja eben diese Spiele im Wesentlichen auch im Browser stattfanden und von daher gar nicht so sehr auf die immer weiter wichtiger werdende mobilwelt skalierten.
So dass sie den Fahrt so weiter nicht verfolgt haben und heute eigentlich im Wesentlichen.
Werbeplattform sind das heißt das Geld was Facebook verdient verdienen sie dadurch.
Dass sie Werbung einblenden und das eben möglichst angepasst und das ist ja genau das.
Feature was dann wiederum Cambridge analytica im Wahlkampf zum Einsatz gebracht hat sprich sie kann die ganzen Profile und konnten dann den Leuten extrem,
target it's Werbung einblenden und Wasser Geier was Sie sonst noch alles gemacht.
Genau deswegen ist das aber auch irgendwie weißt du das große Gelaber jetzt hier irgendwie dass es hier sich um ein Datenleck oder ein Datenskandal oder ein Datenmissbrauch oder sonst was handeln würde teile ich nicht.
Ja das ist ein Gebrauch das wurde zu diesem Zweck dieses gesamte Facebook wurde zu diesem Zweck geschaffen.
Einzige 311 one sich jetzt gerade noch dreht ist,
dass der das im politischen Bereich oh Wunder auch genutzt wird Werte dann hätte jetzt echt keiner mit rechnen können wo gerade der politische breicha dafür bekannt ist so ganz besonders ethisch und nach home nach hohen Standards zu funktionieren ja,
und der ist es ja also wer wer seine Daten dahin wird das S SS echt ist es manchmal dann doch erstaunlich.
Wie man sich wie man sich solche Sachen anschaut über über in dem Fall von Facebook jetzt auch bald zehn Jahre oder was ist dieser dieses Treiben jetzt ihr Unwesen.
It's so oder wahrscheinlich noch viel länger aber seit 10 Jahren.
Belästigen Sie mich durch ihre Existenz ja der Firma Limmer ja natürlich die schicken ihre Leute zu mir und die sagen dann hier bis bei Facebook und dann sage ich nein oder muss ich mich rechtfertigen und so nah sind wir.
Bitte mir auch langweilig mehr denkt man irgendwie ja okay jetzt bin ich langweilig jetzt ist das irgendwie durch den Kampf haben wir verloren.
Oder irgendwie so eine eine ganz offenkundige Wahrheit irgendwie allen schon eben meinte wir allen klar jetzt so ne.
Darf das nämlich eben eine Werbeplattform ist die deren einziger Existenzgrund ist dass ihr da eure Daten eingibt.
Und dass sie euch dann dafür Scheiße verkaufen von anderen Leuten jetzt plötzlich schauen alle auf und sagen.
Wir haben gar nicht zehn Jahre lang mir eine Dienstleistung erwiesen indem sie mich 5 mal am Tag genervt haben dass ich ihn noch irgendwie,
dass sie vermuten dass es noch so ein Byte auf meiner Festplatte gibt was ich da noch nicht hochgeladen habe die E-Mail-Adressen meiner Freunde und Freundesfreunde und Tier Wer ist das mach mal Hilfe.
Meine eigenen p*****.
Hilfiger deine p***** auch immer noch hoch dann wäre doch schade wenn die bei uns veröffentlichen,
und und alle was du die Erfolge hier in Facebook total nett dieser dieser Zuckerberg sowas der du Teddy Menowin meine Freundin die in der Ferne mein Freund in der Ferne mit den kann ich auch reden also.
Was ja auch noch bekannt wurde ist das ja Facebook sich selbst auch nicht mit den Daten begnügt hat diese ohnehin schon angehäuft haben die ja alles andere übersteigen was du andere Marktplätze so zu sich nehmen.
Nein die haben dann eben auch noch die fehlenden Sicherheitsmerkmale der Android Plattform genutzt um.
Auf dem Telefon die die Leute benutzt haben mit dem Facebook klein mal eben dann auch noch mal die SMS Nachrichten durch zu Camp,
weiß ich ob nach Inhalten oder nach nur das wer mit wem weil das wer mit wem ist natürlich an sich interessant aber wir wissen mittlerweile auch dass überhaupt gar keine Probleme haben auch Inhalte zu interpretieren soll ich mal,
unten aber auch halt so.
Pauls Leute haben sie ihre mal ihre Daten runtergeladen bei Facebook so was speichert ihr denn eigentlich über mich die Funktion gibt's ja schon ne Weile und dann festgestellt dass also Telefonnummern von der Oma und so weiter auch abgelegt sind die hat niemals in dieses Profil eingegeben worden.
Alles.
Nicht so schön und vor allem nicht so klar ob das überhaupt auch in irgendeiner Form von ihren eigenen Tanz auf Services abgeht.
Vermutlich mal nicht sprichst ja mal auch einfach nur ganze Menge einfach mal so gemacht.
Nun gibt's Reaktionen ohnehin steht ja durch die.
Danke Grundverordnung ein nicht unerheblicher Umbau der gesamt Funktionalität.
Tschuldigung von Facebook an.
Dazu Predigt Zuckerberg dass sie halt noch weitere Maßnahmen ergreifen und im Rahmen dieser ganzen Cambridge analytica Geschichte haben sie,
jetzt in zwei Schritten die API Zugänge stark beschnitten was wohl auch schon dazu führte dass du Apps wie tinder und so weiter auch einfach erstmal aufgehört haben zu funktionieren weil sie schlicht,
ich möchte Daten erhielten die ist sie sozusagen erwarteten und dann ist das Wasser immer relativ schlecht aufgestellt wenn auf einmal die APIs anders funktionieren als vorher,
und auch so Funktionen wie,
ich suche mal ein Profil über die E-Mail-Adresse was sind convenience Feature ist insbesondere manzo Kontakt Kontakte auf Telefon auslesen dann mal gucken wer ist denn so mein Freund und so,
könnte man ja dann quasi auch mit E-Mail-Adresse was findest unsere Facebook selber kann ich dich auch anders darüber finden aber.
Auch 3 der Saison darüber mit hier ich habe die E-Mail-Adresse sammel mal welches Profil das ist suchen und natürlich auch von vielen Anwendungen.
Kraulen verwendet um einfach da Profile abzugleichen oder überhaupt auch erstmal zu entdecken,
ja das war jetzt alles anders werden wir mal so jetzt angekündigt dass sie eben umfangreiche,
Updates machen werden zu ihren Jobs auf Services und Ihrer Daten Politik generell,
dieser Zugriff auf Freunde ist ohnehin schon einge.
Event Teilnehmer.
Auf mal ganz interessant ist na das ist alles so ging oder Post auf dieser Wahl von Events Mitgliederlisten von Facebook Gruppen werden nicht mehr weitergereicht also heißt immer so viel wie,
so ein Zugriffe möglich bisher ja.
Es werden jetzt auch reviewed von Facebook also das was Apple ja schon immer gemacht hat und.
Ja und wirst du von dem Admin der Gruppe also wenn eine.
Zugriff auf eine Gruppe haben will dann muss dann erstmal guckt Facebook ob man dass dieser App überhaupt genehmigen kann.
Und dann muss der Admin der Gruppe auch noch sagen jo diese App darf bei uns,
darf bei uns mit schnüffeln geschlossene Gruppe nur meine besten Freunde und und Apps dürfen wir betreiben.
Genau Name und Foto bei Kommentaren in einer Facebook Gruppe also gerade dieser ganze Gruppen Kram wird extrem eingeschränkt.
Ja und.
Apps die auf Facebook Seiten zugreifen wollen werden halt auch Review das Review Prozess kommt jetzt hier auf einmal in Fahrt inwiefern der schon vorher überhaupt da war oder was überhaupt geprüft wurde.
Geschweige denn wie groß da die ablehnungsrate war wenn ich sage.
Aber das Gute ist ja das was soll ich echt beruhigen kann ist worauf die Apps in Zukunft kein Zugriff mehr haben dürfen ja was sie vorher hatten religiöse oder politische Einstellung.
Relationship Status also every Beziehungsstatus und Details der Beziehung.
Also mit wem und von wo custom friends list also Freundes Freundesliste die man sich noch mal unter gelistet hat z.b. so wie meine echten Freunde.
Ein richtig richtig guten Freunde und Freunde den ich alles anvertrauen.
Erziehung also nicht erzählt Ausbildung und Arbeit Geschichte also Bomann WA IV Fitness Aktivität.
Buch lese Aktivität Musik hören WC News reading also welche Nachrichten liest welche Videos man schaut und welche Spiele wann spielt so ich.
Viadukt russtandy vorher.
Andererseits was wenn das die Shortlist ist auf diese jetzt kein Zugriff mehr haben wäre die Pose die negative die Positivliste worauf sie noch Zugriff haben länger oder kürzer gewesen.
Also.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so juicy aber da bleibt natürlich auf jeden Fall was übrig weil wenn er nichts mehr da ist gibt halt auch relativ wenig Gründe überhaupt Apps zu machen also warum sollte man überhaupt Apps in dem Facebook Ökosystem unterbringen wenn die sozusagen kein Zugriff auf die Daten haben den das ist ja der einzige Grund,
Warum antasma.
Ja also ich weiß nicht ob man diese diese komische fahr mal Sache da der ob das irgendwie notwendigerweise jedoch wahrscheinlich wurde es gemacht um die Daten zu klauen ja das ist wahrscheinlich dann der Datenskandal in drei Jahren.
Was ist bei Farmville haben Sie noch mal Ihre selber kann und sie ist natürlich auch noch verkauft Konzert.
Haben sie den neuen Teil.
Das war ja dann sozusagen noch mal das Leben Geschäft.
Das ist so geil dieses Internet dich jetzt also hier so ein virtueller linden Dollar oder oder Bitcoin.
Also nicht cryptocurrency sondern halt sowas.
Welche die man einem auf Twitter.
Samen ne damit du dann irgendwie dein Feld auch bestellen kannst und so weiter ne das ist so ja.
Das ist ja auch ein Milliardengeschäft ne.
Na ja was nicht einfällt funktioniert das funktioniert online oder viel besser.
Ich glaube aber dass also diese Betrugsmasche mit den Daten auslesen ist jetzt leicht eingeschränkt worden von Facebook na dann.
Sie selber werden auch eine Fremdarbeit allerletztes der Facebook Android app will not collect calls and SMS weather data anymore.
Sie ist keine.
Na dieses Feature mit dem mit dem ich suche nach Telefonnummer oder E-Mail Adressen und Profil zu finden also.
Achso weil das wurde auch von bösen genutzt weil die natürlich eine Telefonnummer in ihre Finger gekriegt haben ist Ihnen aufgefallen achso.
Das ist ihm jetzt aufgefallen ja nach 14 Jahren haben sie mal verstanden wie man dieses Features hatte die auch benutzen kann.
Ja dann ist ja noch mehr eingefallen was finde ich eigentlich Amacher Gehaltsliste Zuckerberg stellte sich denn jetzt raus hatte für seine privaten Nachrichten die der verschickt hat also Zuckerberg der der.
Eigner von Facebook erfunden hat das ja nicht ne da gab's für diesen diesen lawsuit irgendwann mal wurde diese Zwillinge da.
Ja Mitte sie ja.
Abfertigung musste aber egal der der Eigner von Facebook oder der Chef CEO der hatte so einiges sonder Features in seinem Kanal in seinem Ding.
Z.b. dass er Nachrichten die er verschickt hat ein anderer aus der in Inbox wieder raus klauen kommt.
Also so einen digitalen Radiergummi möchte man mal ne also eigentlich so eine so eine Hardcore aluhut Funktion da wundert man sich sogar unter Wasser Zuckerberg die wohl brauchen.
Beta tester bei Facebook.
Beta-Tester ja demnächst kriegen wir das alle wahrscheinlich kriegen wir das ja.
Genau so sieht's nämlich auch aus also das Feature soll tatsächlich regulär angeboten werden künftig für alle User dass du dann entweder eine Nachricht mit so einer expertime Versehen kannst oder so ähnlich wie bei Instagram.
Und so weiter so Dinge verschwinden automatisch damit angefangen snapchat hatte mit glaube ich angefangen aber ich habe mittlerweile auch irgendwie viele kopiert.
Das ganze dann eben auch noch für Textnachrichten.
Was für uns interessant ist so ich meine es ist ja nur nicht sichtbar oder das ist dann gelöscht ne also so mit diesem dauerhaften löschen ist das ja ohnehin etwas ne also wenn,
morgen die Server Festplattencrash haben und Facebook ist nicht in der Lage im Backup einzuspielen dann wird halt auch schwierig das heißt diese Daten sind natürlich auch,
alle nie weg aber kann überhaupt davon ausgehen dass bei Facebook überhaupt noch nie was gelöscht wurde.
Es wurde eine Menge als gelöscht markiert aber gelöscht wurde dann nix.
Aber bevor das jetzt bevor das jetzt falsch verstanden wird das wiederum ist normal ja dass das die nicht wirklich löschen.
Macht jedes Dateisystem auf dem Computer auch nicht anders sondern das wo der der Datei inhalt vorher stand da wenn ich eine Datei auf einem Computer löscht dann wird nur der Platz wo die vorher stand.
Freigegeben ob und wann dann diese Stelle etwas anderes geschrieben wird das steht noch mal auf einem anderen Blatt.
Wenn man das aber jetzt auf eine Datenbank überträgt.
Dann ist es natürlich auch naheliegend sich diese diese Last zu sparen wirklich eine ganze Zeile aus der Datenbank zu löschen oder von der Festplatte ja also wenn jetzt quasi die hätten,
die Energiekosten der Gesamtaufwand für Facebook wäre teurer wenn sie Sachen immer löschen würden als wenn sie einfach sagen okay,
wir markieren das alles gelöscht.
Er weiß ja noch ein bisschen geht ja noch was immer das betrifft zu den operativen Betrieb ne so aber Backup.
So Mercedes in das könnte.
Die schieben das ja da dann auch irgendwann die haben ja was besser sogar da Facebook die da sogar noch.
Diese Sache mit denen gelasert DVD gemacht habe das auch wieder da Facebook ab,
Balkan und heute auch die müssen sich natürlich über Langzeit Archive Gedanken machen und ich habe da jetzt keine konkreten Einblicke wie das da aussieht aber,
da kann man schwer davon ausgehen dass sie da einfach diverse Keller haben die gut gekühlt sind da liegen einfach Magnetbänder oder Becel mit Laser also.
KTV diesmal Leser zum Auslesen aber zum reinschreiben kann man die sozialen auch so richtig durchlöchern also mechanisch quasi mit dem Laser durchlöchern damit die Daten damit die eben auch richtig.
So richtig physikalisch da sind und so richtig lange halten Serie noch diverse andere Methoden weil man will ja man will ja was haben wenn die Kacke am Dampfen ist ja und.
Natürlich wird Dani gelöscht das ist alles irgendwie da es ist.
Ja Mann.
Aktuelle Datenbank sag halt was es nicht gibt.
Macht ihr jetzt zu Hause auch nicht hoffentlich also wann wann löscht man mal wirklich was also was man bei was man jemals.
Ich kenne so Leute die das hatten aber die haben eigentlich in der Regel auch bereut.
Du bist wie verschlüsselt das Kalorien.
Ja
Gleich mal.
Im übrigen die einzige Möglichkeit wie man ebensolche Backup tatsächlich löschen könnte ist dass man die Daten zwar vorhält aber eben generell verschlüsselt Dickies.
Nicht so dauerhaft ablegt und dann irgendwann fallen lässt das ist in der Tat etwas was ginge oder was ganz konsequent macht dann hat man halt einen mega,
kompliziertes System voneinander abhängen gegen Schlüsselketten wo man einzelne Sachen fallen lassen.
Weißt du wer der letzte ist der sowas bauen würde Facebook.
Ja zumal es ja auch nicht einfach ist und natürlich das Risiko extrem erhöht dass man durch so ein ganz dumm Unfall alles verliert.
Ja du ich habe auch das ein oder andere Mal schon Schweißausbrüche gehabt weil ich dachte ich hätte so einen Unfall.
Und jetzt als Jugendlicher ist zum ersten Mal auch wirklich gehabt das war schlimm.
Dass mein ganzes Leben verloren gegangen bis bis bis ich 14 war sitzt für etwa im Laufe der Zeit relativiert der Verlust aber war ärgerlich.
Wie das immer so ist in solchen kulturellen Phänomen gibt es immer so passende Dinge entweder wird man bei Dilbert fündig oder es gab da mein xkcd dazu gab halt eine Folge von.
Beiß nicht gleich verdammt cartman und Co South Park genau oder es gab eine South Park Folge.
Die beste South Park Folge was ist das schon uralt hier sehen wir uns.
Disco alt ja genau du hast zero friends aber jetzt Zucchini hat ja hat ja auch ein ausgegrauten friend but also auf der Webseite ist wie keiner und immobilen ist ausgegraut weil man kann ihn nicht als Freund hinzufügen.
Merkt euch Mark Zuckerberg ist nicht dein Freund.
Warum.
Und das ist das inhalt auch für Dich wollten diese ganze Geschichte mit er beteuert jetzt dass man irgendwas ändern würde und er hat ja die Fehler verstanden ich habe jetzt leider den Link habe ich irgendwie noch nicht wiedergefunden und muss ich noch mal gucken aber es gab so schöne Zusammenstellung von und wieso den letzten,
14 Jahren Facebook und immer wieder gab es irgendwie ein Vorfall und immer wieder gab's und öffentliche mea culpa,
Meldung von Mark Zuckerberg jetzt mal was aber ganz anders und passiert ist dann immer nichts nichts nichts nichts und dann.
Oh das ist jetzt die Situation in der sich Facebook,
wie erfindet on the werden sehr gespannt lauschen was er so vor dem Kongress von sich gibt sagen es so sehr zweit gefährlichste Mensch irgendwie vor so einem Tribunal sich selber,
ganz tief in die Scheiße zu reden ja also nach Donald Trump.
Deswegen trainiert er jetzt also am I am 11. April muss er dahin und der der trainiert der trainiert den ganzen Tag der irgendwelche Leute den Schulen.
Kein.
Ja das ist.
Da gabs auch irgendwie irgendwo sein hat ihn.
Das war z Kruse von die aus der schönste verrückte texanische Politiker der wurden tatsächlich auf einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung von jemand gefragt ob er beweisen könnte das wäre auch.
Human life form wäre bei Mark Zuckerberg bin ich mir da auch irgendwie nicht so ganz sicher aber das was ist das ist ja etwas polemisch so was machen wir da eigentlich nie.
Nee sowas machen wenn ich.
Nee was also das Problem ansich.
Man kann jetzt einen Facebook Details rumkritzeln wie man will aber das Kernproblem ist und bleibt Facebook ist ein Internet in sich selbst,
und alle Regeln von Facebook werden von Facebook definiert und es scheint irgendwie überhaupt,
keiner Relation zur Außenwelt zu geben facebook lässt sich da nicht ein reinreden,
und Facebook agiert vor allem auch in zunehmendem Maße wie ein eigener Staat mit irgendwie mehrere Milliarden Einwohnern und macht alle Regeln selber und wenn man irgendwas möchte das haben wir ja hier auch in der deutschen Politik,
der letzten Zeit häufiger gesehen dass.
Die Politiker dann sozusagen schön nach Kalifornien fahren und bitte bitte bitte sagen,
könnt ihr nicht mal dass wir uns immer so machen und könnte nicht vielleicht mal um Wien Büro hat bitte die meine Telefonnummer einrichten wo man auch mal euch mal anrufen kann also wird die eine unglaublich höre es,
Verhalten anstatt das noch mal auf den Tisch klopfen und sagt so jetzt regulieren wir das ganze einfach mal.
Dank der datenschutzgrundverordnung wie es den Anschein hat kommt jetzt überhaupt erstmal Bewegung in das Spiel aber das will ich auch.
Dank dieser dank fest falsche Wort Name Susanne Ursache,
eben die Debatte in USA und auch zuletzt in UK summer noch überhaupt gar nicht aufgeräumt was kann ich in dir wann du das mitbekommen hast dass sie die ganze Geschichte ja jetzt auch in.
England noch Welle geschlagen hat da gibt's ja dann noch mal so ein zweites Unternehmen EEG.
Bitte Tim K die wissen anschauen hat im wesentlichen so als Tochterunternehmen von Cambridge analytica willst du mich als extrem enger Partner gesehen werden kann,
dia,
die entsprechende gartendienstleistung für den brexit Wahlkampf gemacht hat also die leave campaign die also für den Austritt Großbritanniens aus der Europäischen Union gewittert hat hat sich also.
Hat extrem viel Geld fast den vollständigen in diese Unternehmen gesteckt um halt hier entsprechend Stimmung zu machen für den Austritt und dafür zustimmen.
Und das ganze kommt jetzt auch gerade in UK unter Feuer,
noch unter einem anderen Aspekt weiß nicht aussieht als ob hier auch noch ordentlich geschummelt wurde von diesen ganzen leave campaign an und am Ende auch entsprechende,
Kampagnen Finanzierungs Gesetze verletzt wurden diese Debatte die Breitscheid geradeso in UK Magdeburg will in vor dem Parlament in UK nicht aussagen,
wenn sehen wie sich das alles entwickelt klappt das noch ne ganze Menge Musik drin.
Wenn dann einmal Datenskandal ist dann geht der Datenskandal natürlich auch seine Runde,
das war sehr interessant in den letzten Tagen auch zu sehen,
also erstmal kam natürlich auch noch eine ganze Menge anderer direkt über Facebook hoch na das irgendwie diese Geschichte vorlesen zum internen Nemo sagt unsere,
unsere Aufgabe ist hier connecting people oder ich glaube sie haben da nicht das Nokia Nokia Slogan direkt verletzt aber so ungefähr und wenn der mal der ein oder andere bei draufgeht weil.
Diese die Offenheit vielleicht den Leuten geschadet hat dann ist das eben einen Preis den wir.
Mich hat unsere Angelegenheit sehen aber dann geht's auch so schöne Sachen wie das würde ich sagen für Erwachsene gedacht.
Asoziale Netzwerk Grinder.
Ada im Rahmen ihrer werbekooperation den HIV Status ihrer Mitglieder.
Mit mit den dritten Parteien geteilt haben auch das kann natürlich bei targeted advertising in äußerst relevanter Faktor sein.
Außerdem gab es dann auch noch so ein kleines Gerede bisher mal schauen was da noch draus wird um die Deutsche Post die sollen nämlich Personendaten ihrer Kunden für Wahlkampf Zwecke an politische Parteien verkauft haben.
Es gibt ja den Deutsche Post direkt GmbH konnte.
Digi die Deutsche Post direkt GmbH eine Tochter des Konzerns die Parteien beteuern aber die deutschen Parteien beteuern diese Daten seien anonymisiert gewesen oder sie hätten halt irgendwie mal so ja in bestimmten.
Stadt für inhalt bestimmte Werbung aus flattern lassen werden wir jetzt mal sehen ob sich das auch noch zu einem Skandal ausweitet oder eher nicht ich würde jetzt mal hoffen und schätzen er nicht.
Man hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck dass alles was jetzt also als hättet jetzt die Menschheit gerade Wahlwerbung überhaupt zum ersten Mal entdeckt na das war auch so ein bisschen was ich glaube ich vor einem Jahr schon zu dem Thema gesagt habe so,
selbstverständlich wird alles getan um irgendwie auf das Ergebnis einer Wahl.
Einfluss zu nehmen nicht alles davon ist jetzt automatisch schlecht aber vieles.
Also bei der Post war es so dass sie halt Daten über Wohnblöcke geliefert haben,
das heißt du hast halt quasi für einen bestimmten Adressbereich Informationen bekommen über wie wurde da gewählt wie es da das Einkommen wie viel Leute wurden da wie alt ist.
Wiedergewählt wurde Christ ja woanders her die Daten.
Ja aber halt korreliert,
die mit diesem Datennutzung auch so ein Blog runtergerechnet fertig zum Auswerten und das war daneben ich glaube für CD und LP,
IP Datenmaterial wird dieser Inhalt entsprechende Werbung losgeschickt haben das ist natürlich nicht das gleiche was jetzt hier bei Facebook gelaufen ist weil da war das natürlich hochgradig,
individuell und auf die einzelne Person ganz konkret einschließlich der sonstigen Vorlieben und der Rechtsneigung,
zugeschnitten und von daher ist das jetzt nicht in derselben Liga aber ist derselbe Sport.
Genau und das ist aber beim bei Sport.
Gibt's immer diese wird ONE wieso diese unscharf nicht ganz klare Linie wo der Sport auf einmal unfair Vietnam da wird ja auch irgendwie immer wieder neu neu verhandelt.
Wir werden gespannt bleiben ich bin auf jeden Fall erfreut über diese späte Erkenntnis die hier vielen Leuten zuteil wird.
Und hoffe natürlich dass da möglichst irgendeine Form von.
Juristischen capital raus geschlagen wird das solche solchen Geschäftsmodellen in irgendeiner Form einen Riegel vorgeschoben wird er sie eingeschränkt werden nahe Frank Rieger hatte ja schon jetzt sind wir in einem Gasvertrag.
Die Zerschlagung von Facebook gefordert das wäre natürlich sehr schön noch lieber wäre mir aber natürlich wenn die einfach an sich selber kapieren würden bei keiner mehr hingeht so stell dir vor es ist Facebook und keiner geht hin.
Ja die stattfinden.
Dann wiederum muss man sich eben überlegen ob man nicht vielleicht doch draufhaut ne irgendwie da also ich bin mal gespannt was sich jetzt hier noch alles so,
finden wir aber das Facebook existieren würde damit ihr mit euren Freunden oder Freundin im Ausland kommunizieren können das ist glaube ich eine.
Eine mehr die die sollte sich jetzt nicht mehr über den teilten.
Ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt vieles wird getan und versucht um auf den auf den Ausgang einer Wahl Einfluss zu nehmen.
Und eine auch recht alte Beschuldigung ist natürlich immer in der Regel macht der Russe der Russe ist schuld.
Russische was.
Der Russe war es und so wurde Russland ja auch beschuldigt.
2016 im US amerikanischen Präsidentschaftswahlkampf in die Computersysteme der Demokratischen Partei,
eingegriffen eingestiegen zu sein dort Daten insbesondere E-Mails auch kapiert zu haben und die wohnen ja dann teilweise von Wikileaks.
Veröffentlicht.
Und dafür zeichnete verantwortlich ein Hacker mit dem Decknamen Luzifer oder Gucci Fähre ich weiß nicht wie man das ausspricht.
Gucci Gucci Gucci Gucci face ach jetzt gut Schiffer gut FIFA 2.0.
Wer sagte ich war das ganze alleine habe ich selber gemacht und hier ich habe nur WordPress-Blog bei wordpress.com und bitte Account und.
Da mische ich mich auch selber noch so ein bisschen mit ein er bezog sich mit diesem Namen auf gut Schiff A1 einen rumänischen Hacker der leider erwischt wurde.
Marcela Daniel weil so leider ist es vielleicht auch nicht der hatte eine Reihe von Hacks gegen berühmte halten und Politiker vorgenommen und die so ein bisschen.
Auch in die Öffentlichkeit Getränke um den geht's heute nicht sondern um unseren Gucci fatu point auf.
Der sich quasi zur.
Zu Ehren von Gucci Vereins so benannt hatte und sagte ich bin also auch hier ein Rumäne er hat dann auch noch so einen.
Interview dem Motherboard gegeben Vice Motherboard you es indem er.
Es ist also eine E-Mail.
Interview und das wurde von Motherboard aus der Gehalt da gab es ebenfalls sehr viel sehr viel ist die darauf hindeuten dass er wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht der Rumäne ist für den er sich ausgibt und der seid ihr da auch über einige politische Ansichten noch gesagt oder.
Was macht er alles nicht so ganz hin für Leute die sich mit der Materie wirklich aus Kanten.
Und aber er sagte in seinem ursprünglichen Blogpost dass er das war dieser TNT hack also Democratic National Council hat und dass er irgendwie gegen die Illuminati vorgehen wollte und.
Hat dein auch immer mal wieder so ein paar E-Mails dargelegt oder Dateien gelegt sie hat eine sehr entscheidende Rolle gespielt in diesen ganzen hacking Angriffen auf.
Die demokratische Partei.
Wikileaks hat aber dann den größeren Teil veröffentlicht am 22 July gut FIFA hatte aber auch schon gesagt dass ich das alles dass er das alles ruhig gelegt geben hatte.
Wikileaks hat deine seitdem behauptet ja nee wir können weder bestätigen noch.
Dementieren das Gucci farpoint auch hier die Quelle war wie das eben so ist wir reden hier von 19 Uhr ungefähr 19011 und 8000 Edmonds.
Und jetzt Zeitsprung ne längere Zeit später die Russia investigation.
Hört ja nicht auf ne Facebook mit seinem Käfig analytica kommt,
erst jetzt wirklich damit unter die Räder wo nämlich der Maler an der Sache dran hängt,
ja und das Spiel schließt sich vielleicht natürlich auch der Kreis warum jetzt auf einmal ist sehr viel mehr Interesse daran gibt sich diese Sache auch wirklich anzuschauen weil natürlich auch die Amerikaner diese,
diese Peinlichkeit loswerden wollen und natürlich nach allem suchen was man den Mann Schuld geben kann,
das jetzt dieser dieser Irre regiert ich habe mich letzte Woche wieder mit ein paar.
Amerikanern längere Zeit unterhalten und es war wirklich.
Das hat mir richtig Spaß gemacht dass man so bei jeder Gelegenheit mal so einfach so einen kleinen Seitenhieb auf Trump machen konnte und die immer wieder so ganz so ein sind so 10 cm weiter nidegger am Tisch gesagt sind weil sie.
War auf jeden Fall ganz amüsant.
Immer auf die Schwachen.
Ja auf dich ich glaube die werden sich schon noch schnell genug erholen und wenn sie wieder ihr Land in Schutt und Asche legen und hasse,
die stolz geschwellter Brust des amerikanischen gegenüber zwei relativ leicht in ihrem Winkel zu beeinflussen hier je mehr man das Gespräch in Richtung Trump lenkte sie mal aber natürlich auch wie sehr diese Leute darunter leiden.
Jedenfalls ob nun Gucci farpoint von Russland gesteuert war oder nicht.
War bis vor kurzem noch unklar und natürlich weitreichende Konsequenzen für diese Maler investigation weil nämlich Roger stone.
Der politische Berater von Donald Trump sogar schon zugegeben hat dass er Zeit im August 2016.
Über Twitter DMS Mitgutsch Eva kommuniziert hat dieser Gucci Fall ist ja rum gerannt und hat ja Vater überall seine.
Er sein seine Hack Ergebnisse da anbieten wollen.
Um den zu Wirkung zu verhelfen und jetzt kommt der Clou.
Offenbar hat unser guter Gucci war in der Regel bei der Arbeit JP ein Genuss einen VPN Dienst der.
Dessen Hochzeit hier in Russland ist der aber z.b. auch ein Access Point in Frankreich hat ist nicht ungewöhnlich gehst zum VPN Anbieter.
Und Bänder unter Umständen hat er auch die Option dass du in verschiedenen Ländern rauskommst diese.
Hör mal sein dass man da mal ein Video gucken was.
Kann erstmal sein dass man mein Video in der Sprache des Landes schauen möchte oder Fußball Übertragungsrechte dieses Jahr irgendwie nicht so günstig verkauft wurden und und und gibt viele Gründe warum man in einem anderen Land,
sein möchte im Internet und diesen Dienst hat der Gucci verwohl genutzt und bei einer.
Einzigen.
Gelegenheit hat er offenbar das VPN nicht aktiviert bevor er sich in sein bevor er sich wo eingeloggt hat ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es jetzt bei WordPress oder bei Twitter war.
Und als Ergebnis hinterließ er eine echte in Moskau beheimatete IP-Adresse.
In den Server Logs einer.
Eine Social Media Unternehmen ja also fitter oder WordPress im Zweifelsfall die haben sich dazu.
WordPress.com.
Website, also was ist ja eine Open-Source-Software es gibt aber auch einen kommerziellen Anbieter WordPress.com der eben mit seinem Dienstleistungsangebot dort einen WordPress-Blog zu hosten.
Auch den den Spaß finanziert oder Teil wahrscheinlich wer finanziert die Entwicklung dieses WordPress.
Ja so jetzt hat unser Gott Schäfer dummerweise also eine IP-Adresse dagelassen und.
Geschichte geht weiter des untersuchten Untersucher inzwischen sogar schon den spezifischen,
Offizier des GRUB den skizzierten zu dem diese IP-Adresse gehört,
jetzt weiß man nicht ob der gute GNU am Arbeitsplatz feste IP Adressen hat das würde ich für unwahrscheinlich halten.
Es kann aber natürlich sein dass sie vielleicht auf anderen Wegen,
Korrelationen gemacht habe oder dass sie die Tür beobachtet habe geguckt haben wir zu welchen Zeiten rein und raus geht das,
da gibt's verschiedene Möglichkeiten wie Sie an diese Information gekommen sind gibt's natürlich auch ganz krasse NSA Überwachungsmöglichkeiten die man sich da vorstellen kann dazu weiß man nichts.
Was nicht an der Sache stutzig macht ist also.
Dass das VPN VPN Verbindung von dem Host hergestellt wird an dem ich auch den Tag Sport treibe.
Das habe ich mir in meiner frühen Jugend abgewöhnt damit nämlich genau sowas nicht passiert.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass oder ist er das ist.
Amüsant vorzustellen dass da irgendwie der der GAU Agent irgendwie zur Arbeit geht morgens sein Computer anmacht und Safaga hier VPN an.
Jetzt mal sicher.
Und jetzt hex-hex ja oder wieder VPN aus E-Mails holen oder so ne man sollte das predige ich auch immer wieder.
Diese Verbindung möglichst nicht von dem Haus herstellen lassen auf dem man den Sport betreibt,
ja dann geh man sich zwei für und sorgt dafür dass der eine den anderen Nieren wohin lässt.
Und alles was der andere irgendwo will unbedingt in dieses Internet wird bei sonst passieren haben immer wieder so Sachen das aus welchen Gründen auch außerhalb des VPN mal ein Ping irgendwo hingeht oder hoch das VPN mal,
kurz die Verbindung verliert und dann hast du schnell einmal falsch geklickt und dann sieht das immer.
Ja oder man ist feines verbunden über IP V4 aber nicht über IP V6 und.
Genau also was das immer alles garnicht haben ne man macht.
Seinen Router davor und man hat dafür entsprechende IP tables und so aber wem sag ich das gut Skifahren und im Zweifelsfall eh nicht verstehen und hat die Lektion ja jetzt auch eh gelernt.
Ja das könnte noch in im Rahmen dieser Maler investigations ein größeres Thema werden.
Weil hier natürlich diese gesamte.
Wir erinnern uns was ich dafür Diskussion gab ihm da E-Mails angeboten wurden und wer die haben wollte und dieser Papadopoulos und so nah das könnte da jetzt noch mal alles.
Sehr viel interessanter werden wobei dann natürlich auch wieder die Rolle spielen für die spielen würde wussten sie es zu dem Zeitpunkt oder nicht.
Also da bin ich auf den Abschlussbericht von Maler gespannt auf dem ich eh schon seit längerem gespannt geht's mir auch so.
Ja wir warten alle aber ich glaube.
Wieso er könnte mal langsam fertig werden wenn denk sieverner See wenn er noch ein bisschen länger braucht auch damit der Kot.
Bitte sehr noch mehr ja.
Dann lass ihn ruhig ne aber.
Da sind auch hier mit meinen amerikanischen Freunden die Gespräche da ist jetzt auch die Hoffnung inzwischen sehr gering dass jetzt ausgerechnet der Maler ist am Ende Schaft in den Trump dann noch zu Kanten.
Aber das ein anderes Thema.
Bitte aber für die Wahlen die jetzt anstehen schon einen Einfluss haben.
Ja für die die demokratischen finde ich für die demokratischen Wahl für die mithören élections da wir auch Rechenspiele gemacht aber der springt jetzt nur wissen das Thema soviel kann die Demokraten da auch nicht,
Erla.
Also sie können den Senat auf jeden Fall Easy gewinnen weil da ist ja nur noch eine Stimme die fehlt.
Der hat aber nicht so viele Rechte wie andere und so also.
Damit geht aber dann schon mal einiges schon mal nicht mehr so was jetzt noch ohne weiteres möglich ist ne also gerade hier so tax reform und sowas das Wetter halt schon nicht mehr drin und es ist auch nicht komplett ausgeschlossen dass sie den Kongress wieder zurückholen aber,
das wenn wir dann alles sehen schaue mir lieber nach Bayern.
Bleiben wir bei unseren Kernkompetenzen ja f****** und Überwachung.
Bayern soll ein neues Polizeigesetz bekommen.
Für die Heimat.
Für die für den bayerischer Heimatschutz braucht die Unterstützung.
Um um Kriminelle zu finden die es noch vielleicht gar nicht gibt.
Genau das ist ja das neue Thema wir sind ja längst davon weg.
Dass wir uns in der für die Strafverfolgung stärken das brauchen wir nicht mehr so gut wie in der sie haben wir jetzt einmal durch geduldige.
Stärkt wär was dummerweise jetzt natürlich immer mehr Leuten auffällt ist das.
Dadurch die Kriminalität ja trotzdem nicht singt.
Und dass man ja eigentlich quasi dass das schönste wäre ja wenn man die Kriminalität eindämmen oder die Kriminalität verfolgt bevor sie entsteht.
Dazu muss ich glaube ich noch mal anmerken und jetzt die Zahlen konkret zu kennen aber ist ja nicht so dass die Kriminalität ansteigen würde also wenn man sich so die Entwicklung der letzten Jahre anschaut sitzt ja eigentlich besser.
Es wird Eis wird alles besser deswegen verstehe es ist tatsächlich netto wird alles immer besser wenn es für euch immer schlechter wird dann kriegt ihr nur halt die falsche Scheibe von dem besser aber insgesamt wird alles immer besser.
Wie tief ist.
Wie auch diese Sendung auch wenn euch das nicht so auffällt.
Also was,
Bayern möchte möchte mehr Kompetenzen für die Polizei haben stellt sich raus wir haben schon alle Kompetenzen das einzige was jetzt noch machen könnten wäre eine neue neue neue,
Gegebenheiten definieren unter denen diese Kompetenzen auch zum Einsatz gebracht werden können und dann sie etwas Neues erfunden nämlich eine,
drohende Gefahr drohende Gefahr ist wenn die Gefahr noch nicht da ist.
Oder oder nichts passiert ist.
Aber es könnte sein dass es gefährlich werden könnte und na dann quasi da gehst du über den begründeten Anfangsverdacht noch mal hinaus und sagst wir haben drohende Gefahr.
Und wenn das wenn drohende Gefahr ist dann können wir folgendes tun.
Es heißt also es muss keine Straftat begangen sein es reicht aus wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit begründet ist das in überschaubarer Zukunft eine Straftat begangen wird wenn das der Fall ist.
Dann hat die Polizei ihr gesamtes Arsenal.
Zur Verfügung dazu gehört unter anderem Online-Durchsuchung Überwachung von Telefon und Handy Überwachung der Post Funkzellenabfrage funkzellendaten abfragen und damit ein Bewegungsprofil erstellen.
Man braucht dafür natürlich noch ein Richterberichte Vorbehalt der Sinne Richter Bescheid richterlichen Bescheid nee wie heißt das denn eine richterliche Anordnung.
Also das ist das ist das ist diese Unterschrift wenn sich am Freitag Nachmittag kurz bevor die Richter ins Wochenende gehen wollen noch mal kurz abholt.
Und jetzt sagen was was was muss in Gefahr sein für wen muss diese drohende Gefahr bestehen für ein bedeutendes Rechtsgut und bedeutende Rechtsgüter sind Leben Gesundheit Freiheit.
Aber auch Dinge deren Erhalt im besonderen öffentlichen Interesse sind.
Und da sagt der Vorsitzende des Verfassungsschutzes Franz Schindler der bei der SPD ist also mit anderen Worten,
irgendwo in der Nähe der 5% in Bayern sag das jetzt z.b. so ein Strommast oder so ja das heißt also irgendwie alles was irgendwie ein.
Ein bedeutendes Rechtsgut ist dem hier eine drohende Gefahr einer drohenden Gefährdung ausgesetzt ist darf dann eben da zum kompletten.
Finde kompletten Ermittlungsmaßnahmen führen.
Gibt's paar Stellungnahmen zu Richter am Landgericht München Markus Löffelmann sagt er diese ein überhaupt die Einführung der Kategorie drohende Gefahr ist eine nicht mehr akzeptable Herabsetzung der polizeilichen Eingriffsschwelle.
Im Prinzip das andauernd eine Gefahr droht ne Leben ist eine einzige drohende Gefahr.
Ja endete das sicher auch belegen.
Es wird immer gefährlicher.
Ja es endet vor allem von nahezu immer mit dem Tod heimatminister kommt.
Markus Möstl,
Lehrstuhl für öffentliches Recht an der Universität Bayreuth sagt hingegen das ist hier auf sicherem Boden verfassungsrechtlich was wir aber hier ganz klar haben ist das die Trennung von Polizei und Geheimdienst zuzusehen schwindet na also.
All diese überwachungs und Ermittlungs Werkzeuge im Prinzip ohne nennenswerten Anfangsverdacht und ohne Straftat.
Einsetzen zu können das ist schon allerhand und wird jetzt in Bayern sie ja die auch nicht unbedingt spärlich zur Anwendung kommen weil in Bayern sind die Leute ja sehr eifrig.
Und sich bewusst und so natürlich auch die bayerische Polizei dafür bekannt immer zu gucken wie sie ihre Pflicht vielleicht noch in noch mehr erfüllen könnte.
DNA-Analysen wollen wir natürlich auch haben.
Der bayerische Innenminister Herrmann nennt dafür selber ein Beispiel die Polizei entdeckt irgendwie eine Potenz bei einem potenziellen Bombenleger die Werkstatt ja sind ja aber der ist gar nicht da also Polizei der Bombenleger ist nicht da.
Die Polizei hat aber trotzdem schon die Werkstatt gefunden und jetzt kann sie dort DNA-Spuren finden.
Weil der Bombe hatte gerade nicht da also bleibt nur die Möglichkeit keinen keiner weiß wie die Werkstatt gefunden haben ohne in Bombenleger aber.
Jetzt sind sie da und nehmen im DNA-Spuren auf und jetzt können Sie daraus werden auch schon vor einigen Wochen drüber gesprochen ein Phantombild generieren.
Weil du weil sie immer aus dieser DNA meinen Herkunft Hautfarbe Haarfarbe Geschlecht Augenfarbe und so weiter herausholen zu soll können und sagen dann das aber immerhin sehr viel besser.
Als wenn wir hier irgendwie so ein Phantombild zeichnen würden jetzt ist die Frage wie sie Faust der Vers der Werkstatt das Phantombild wiederum zeichnen wollen das ist aber hier out-of-scope.
Wir haben beim Kongress dazu den Vortrag gehabt von.
Adora Bell zu der extended DNA analysis das habe ich ja glaube ich auch schon mal empfohlen den Vortrag in dem relativ.
Doch habe ich du hast mir nur wieder nicht zugehört.
Deine einfachen Erklärung immer.
Habe ich hier schon mal erwähnt weil wir im anderen Fall zu dieser DNA-Analyse schon gesprochen haben.
Und diese Methode ist in bei weiten nicht so treffsicher wie die Polizei hier hofft in diesem Gesetz.
Ansonsten wenn eine drohende Gefahr besteht darf die Polizei dann,
präventiv und verdeckt auf informationstechnische Systeme zugreifen um Zugangsdaten und gespeicherte Daten zu erheben das ist online Durchsuchung das gilt auch wenn die Speicher räumlich,
von dem von dem Betroffenen genutzten informationstechnischen Systemen getrennt sind das heißt also Cloud.
Verdeckter Online-Durchsuchungen zu Hause und in der Cloud bei Clan der wenn alles in die Cloud muss dann natürlich auch die online ich suche.
Und.
Außerdem in die Telekommunikation präventiv eingreifen und Kommunikationsverbindung durch den Einsatz technischer Mittel unterbrechen oder verhindern das ist auch relativ krass.
Kommunikations.
Verbindung zu verhindern da weiß ich gar nicht worauf sie damit hinaus wollen weil das ist nach meinem Dafürhalten eine Straftat und wenn man das jetzt gezielt macht.
Also wenn man es ungezählt macht dann wenn sie Leute unter Umständen vom Notdienst vom Notruf abschneiden was nicht so einfach rechtlich möglich ist wenn sie.
Gezielt machen dann frage ich mich welche Kommunikation sie da unterbinden wollen ich glaube da geht's ihm wahrscheinlich darum dass sie denken okay Telegramm kucken oder wo auch immer die.
Leute sich verbinden dort irgendwie zu unterbinden oder so.
Auf jeden Fall auch eine äußerst drastische.
Ein äußerst drastischer Einschnitt dass sie jetzt noch nicht mal mehr sagen wir wollen überwachen oder so Sonne wir wollen auch noch unterbrechen und verhindern und jetzt muss man dazu sagen dieser Gesetzesentwurf umfasst 200 Seiten.
Und da kann man natürlich noch viel mit reinschreiben deswegen so zu guter Letzt haben sie gesagt wir wollen auch noch Handgranaten benutzen dürfen auch das.
Die Polizei.
Explosiv wie Handgranaten wollen sie auch noch einsetzen ja.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ob nur bei einer drohenden Gefahr ich schätze mal da wollen Sie wahrscheinlich dann doch auch irgendwie eine akute Gefahr aber ja Handgranaten wollen sie auch noch.
So 200 Seiten Gesetzesentwurf das ist äußerst viel.
Also ich weiß nicht genau ich habe ja den ein oder anderen Gesetzesentwurf schon mal von vorne bis hinten durchgelesen 200 Seiten habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Das heißt nicht dass es vielleicht doch häufiger mal 200 Seiten werden.
Aber hier haben selbst die Experten Sachverständigen angemerkt dass die Materie relativ komplex sein aber.
Im Landtag soll dann in derselben Anhörung noch ein weiteres Gesetz besprochen werden und schon am 26 April soll dieses Gesetz eben.
Landtag verabschiedet werden das ist übrigens hier der Start des Vorverkaufs für LMP.
Das doch von langer Hand.
Das haben die natürlich nur gemacht um uns zu ärgern.
Aldi Verkäufer anzukurbeln je nachdem wenn die Bedrohung das mal klar wird.
Also die bedrohende gefahren.
Da ist nur Ticket kaufen.
Über Zweckmäßigkeit des Gesetzes oder Praxistauglichkeit wurde gar nicht erst gesprochen sagt Marie birklingen zu über diese über diese Anhörung bei netzpolitik.org über die Verfassungskonformität gab es kein abschließendes Urteil,
Praxistauglichkeit und Zweckmäßigkeit wurde überhaupt keine fachkundigen geladen ist von einfach nur Juristen,
und so wird der Teil eben in Bayern durchgeboxt jetzt kannst du ja zwei dreimal raten wer Deutscher Innenminister ist.
Na der Heimat Horst.
Der Heimat Horst und der Heimat Horst für das sicherlich alles sehr gut und ich kann mir sehr wenn ich jetzt mal so völlig utopisch.
Orakeln Daphne dystopisch Orakel das könnte ich mir vorstellen dass der Heimat Horster so mir san mir und das könnt ihr euch auch oder wie auch immer das aussprechen würde und dann hat er ruckzuck hier ne.
Ja was sind Bayern funktioniert.
Heimat Horst Plag.
Muss man doch auch irgendwie muss man doch auch bundesweit einführen also das auf jeden Fall alles außer ist das gruselig.
Ich kann schon ganz fasziniert dass man sogar in Fußballstadien dagegen Wetters also das so Fußball Fankurven sich gegen so eingesetzt aussprechen das schon.
Werden 1860 oder.
Ich glaube ich in mehreren Staaten ich bis um 4 Uhr gesehen also ist ja auch offiziell Bayern.
Und da wo du dagegen protestiert sicherlich jetzt nicht eine Massenbewegung aber ich fand es auch kulturell ganz interessant wo sozusagen das niederschlägt weil.
Bei der Spielvereinigung Greuther Fürth.
Spielvereinigung Greuther Fürth.
Ja kannst mal sehen das wird jetzt langsam modernen sich als Fussballfan Gruppe auch mal politisch zu.
In zunehmendem Maße ich würde jetzt noch nicht von dem Bundestrend sprechen aber.
Also gibt's ja bei Rostock schon länger.
Ja wieder durchs auf Dich auf den Knopf oder was.
Ja bei St. Pauli auch.
Ja also das ist auf jeden Fall.
Haarsträubend und ich also ich hätte ja da mal so aus dem aus dem Bauch heraus erhebliche verfassungsrechtliche Bedenken.
Badarmatur und von daher kann ich da nicht.
Also die Nummer ne dir geht in Bayern.
Verhalten.
Durch wie auf Butter da brauchst du dir keine Sorgen zu machen.
Personell fehlt die Verabschiedung die ist sicherlich ungefährdet die Frage ist nur.
Zeige wie kriegt das wieder weg geklagt.
Ja das kann ich nicht beantworten aber ich meine.
Da müssen wir uns an malte spitz und Ulf buermeyer wenden.
Dann am sharefile für die BFF ne bitte kommen.
Das wäre jetzt so ein Fall für die gfff brauchen also ich habe.
Ja ich meine wenn jetzt schon ehemaliger Verfassungsrichter sagen dass sei nicht nachvollziehbar ist schon krass.
Verfassungsrechtlich bedenklich da hätte ich ja dann auch so meine Zweifel gehabt aber nicht nachvollziehbar schon statement.
Schöne neue Welt.
Kommen wir und diesmal wirklich wirklich wirklich bitte bitte bitte für den Kurzmeldung.
Erstmal ja.
In Saudi-Arabien ist.
Kann man jetzt Konzerte anschauen und ruckzuck abnehmen Autofahren.
Kraftwerke hätten wir da gab es einen einen hacking Angriff,
auf ein Kraftwerk.
Und da haben die Angreifer das sogenannte triconex safety instrumented System des Herstellers Schneider Electric wieder eine Rolle spielt und ich würde daran erinnert.
In der letzten seiner ich gesagt hat oder vorletzten Sinn und wann haben wir noch mal Schneider über Schneider Electric gesprochen und dann meintest du haben wir nie drüber gesprochen und dann wurde aber kommentiert ich habe den Kommentar jetzt leider nicht in der Hand.
Schneider Electric war auch der Hersteller von diesem netbotz Dingern diesen Überwachungssystem die angeblich von der NSA eine Backdoor hatten die zu Überwachung von.
Serverräumen und so genutzt wurden.
Krieg der triconex safety instrumented System er kommt in Öl Gas und Atomkraftwerken zum Einsatz und dient dazu in kritischen Situationen vorher festgelegte Routinen auszuführen also z.b. weiß ich nicht.
Hier.
Atomkern ist zur Warmwasser drauf oder so na das Sehen Vinod Notabschaltung solche Scherze und davon wurden weltweit 13.000 Systeme verkauft und.
13 Uhr.
Ja und so ein Ding wo dir Zeit in Saudi-Arabien in die wurde halt gebaut,
Experten von fireeye sagen das scheint wohl ein staatlicher Akteur gewesen zu sein der Schneider Electric sagt na ja um die Sicherheitslücke in dem Ding zu finden müssen Leute erst mal so in mehrere 10000 € teure System besessen haben um den zu testen bei uns haben,
Kids in letzter Zeit keine Hacker bestellt sowie haben keine Privatkunden gehabt so also vermuten sie dass es irgendwie.
Staatliche Akteure ansonsten sagt Schneider Electric noch die Infektion mit Schadsoftware wäre nicht möglich gewesen wenn der Betreiber der Anlage die Sicherheitsvorschriften beachtet hätte Klammer auf das bedeutet bitte nicht in einem,
am öffentlichen Netz betreiben sondern es war halt offenbar nicht vollständig isoliert ja okay so ist es aber auch leider heute es wird.
Wenn irgendwo so ein Kupferkabel in der Nähe ist ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht klein dass da Internet drauf ist.
Ja dass das heißt das entschuldigt nicht den Mangel in eurem Produkt.
Zudem sei die Schwachstelle im Controller nicht die Ursache der Attacke gewesen damit meine ich natürlich wieder ja die Angreifer sind irgendwo anders reingekommen.
Kritisch deshalb weil dieses Ding eben 13000 fahre in der Welt verkauft wurde und kritisch auch deshalb weil.
Die forensischen Analysten sagen ziel des Angriffs sei hier gewesen einen Schaden herbeizuführen und zwar ein der so groß ist dass unter anderem auch Menschenleben gefährdet.
Worden wären.
Und nur durch einen Fehler in deren Angriff also in einem back in deren Angriffs Routine hat dieser Angriff am Ende nicht.
So funktioniert dieses beabsichtigt haben.
Schwein gehabt sagt man dazu.
Schweigert sagt man dazu,
aber das ist insgesamt natürlich mit sehr viel Sorge zu betrachten wenn hierzu diese Meldung kommen jetzt häufiger,
regelmäßiger Erhalt,
es ging irgendwann mal los mit stocks nicht dann war lange Zeit Ruhe dann haben wir auf einmal diesen kalten Hochofen in Deutschland gehabt diese Stahl Fertigteilwerk und das geht jetzt dann in der Ukraine war auf einmal kalt weil da Heizkraftwerke ausgeschaltet wurden und so das geht jetzt irgendwie in einem Ford das wird also normal.
Das ist nicht gut.
In den Niederlanden auch hier wieder Kongresstag sagen ich habe ja noch einen Job als.
Für dich.
Bagdad Schmerzwellen slutever Referendum da haben fünf Studierende,
sich gegen das überwachungsgesetz gewendet was die Niederlanden über geholfen werden wollte,
sie hatten keine Hilfe von ihr welchen Großparteien sie hatten keinen großartige Finanzierung keinen Verband niemanden der sie großartig unterstützt hat.
Aber es ist ihm gelungen ein Referendum auf die Beine zu stellen landesweit dafür mussten sie 300 000 Unterschriften in sechs Wochen sammeln und das ist ihnen gelungen.
Und das.
Gesetz heißt SWAT also Schleppnetz.
LM Möglichkeiten würde da neben dem niederländischen Geheimnis ermöglichen jegliche Online-Kommunikation von Bürgern und Bürgerinnen abzuhören und für drei Jahre zu speichern.
Wenn sich z.b. ihrer Nachbarschaft ein vermeintlicher Terrorist befindet also auch hier wieder drohende Gefahr wie ein Fischer mit einem stecknitz dürft die Behörden ungezählt alles abgreifen was sie kriegen können.
Und dürfen diese Daten ungefiltert mit ausländischen Partnern teilen so lesen wir das bei netzpolitik.org von Simon drebinger beschrieben und den der, Stock ist nicht viel gesagt auch sehr an,
Herz gelegt von diesen jungen Studierenden jetzt ist interessant wie wird die Regierung reagieren na ja erstens.
Die Befragung war nicht bindend ja das werden also dieses Referendum hat ist einfach nur nicht bindend das heißt da wo du jetzt meine Meinung eingeholt und die kannst du den Akten gelegt werden.
Die brexit.
Na da der war doch bin oder war nicht finden okay aber deswegen also nachher die Wahl gemacht ne.
Ja das ist ja auch ein bisschen schief gegangen aber.
Da ist eine ganze Menge schiefgegangen Tim aber wir wollten die Kurzmeldung ja kurz.
Ja ich bereue mein Einwurf ich dachte nur ich könnte hier mal aus meinem Leiden Hintergrund oder malen Wismar.
Wenn ich ein brexit Witz machen dann guckst du immer ganz ganz ganz ganz böse mit deinem laserblick.
Das hängt halt ganz vom Witz ab ne.
Bitte sei teilweise bereits zwei Wochen bevor die Menschen in der Lenden zu der Urne gerufen wurden hat das niederländische Parlament direkt erstmal für die Abschaffung jeglicher konsultativer Referenten gestimmt das heißt im Sattel also das,
nee dann machen wir nicht noch mal.
Oh, denn dahin wenn ich die Leute aber mal ihre Meinung kund und das nicht bindenden also nicht binden als consultative heißt nicht bindende Referenz die sind abgeschafft worden könnt Meyer Referendum starten um das zu verhindern.
Nee hast du gesagt geht auch nicht über das Gesetz zur Abschaffung der Referenten ist kein weiteres Referendum möglich.
Fuq.
Ja viel Spaß so so so kriegt ihr die nächste Generation politikverdrossen.
Frei Haus mit Amazon.
Ja die Meldung werden immer kürzer.
Spectre fixes lassen auf sich warten ja also Insel ich weiß nicht hast du schon irgendwas davon gehört dass du ein Prozessor microcode-update hattest was sich irgendwie was die respektlos.
Kein Microcode up tall so Diane.
Also sie haben teilweise für einige ältere.
Kurz mal Hintergrund wir reden jetzt von diesem Security Problem dass nicht alle Prozessoren speziell.
Alete Prozessoranzahl noch andere Prozessoren aber auf jeden Fall Intel-Prozessoren letzten 20 Jahre betrifft und Führung und der andere Prozessoren.
Wurden bereits sogenannte Microcode Updates bereitgestellt also die Möglichkeit Quali die Firmware im Prozessor selber zu ändern ja.
Gibt's aber nicht für alle.
Stellt sich jetzt irgendwie die Reinraum Handschuhe ausgezogen und gesagt ich glaube wir sind fertig,
einerseits haben sie für alte nee Harlem Prozessoren sind 9 Jahre alt schon fixes herausgebracht einerseits die jüngere teilweise Jahre wollen das nicht machen und ich glaube dass du sogar irgendwie Kurzweil,
Duo bleibt ungepatchte und so also lassen jetzt.
Wie lasse ich einiges zu liegen und ich hatte das ja glaube ich auch schon als dieser Bug das erste Mal Zimmer war gesagt das ist ein Problem dass es so groß dass es im Zweifelsfall einfach nicht lösen.
Ja na und es sieht.
Weil geht nicht.
Ja das war vielleicht andere Putzzeug verwenden künftig.
Dann werden wir glaube ich nur.
Einfach weiter nichts zu zu sagen gibt wir das aber trotzdem irgendwie Chronisten mäßig mit aufnehmen müssen das ist ja irgendwie in der vergangenen Woche diese Schießerei bei YouTube gab.
Wo eine Youtuberin am sich benachteiligt fühlte durch die.
Ich bestimmte Maßnahmen die sie meinte die YouTube ergriffen habe.
Die um ihr zu schaden oder die zur Folge hat dass ihr geschadet die für sie weniger Geld gebracht haben also.
Insbesonderes Ihre Videos irgendwie für Erwachsene freigeschaltet wurden wodurch die Zuschauerzahlen natürlich sinken weil man nicht mehr das Video schauen kann wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist und.
Irgendwie ihre Monetarisierung auch irgendwie schlechter geworden ist und daraufhin hatte sie.
Ja hat sie dann in einem offenbar Zustand der Verwirrung über den sich auch die Familie Sorgen gemacht hat sich dann aufgemacht zu,
YouTube es gibt auf jeden Fall viele die sich darüber beschweren dass da eine Demo notarisierung stattfinde und sie weniger,
Geld umsetzen auf YouTube insofern kann ich aber jetzt nicht beurteilen.
Ihr Vorwurf da stimmt oder nicht das müssen wir vielleicht in den anderen einer anderen Sendung erweitern ihre Reaktion stimmt auf jeden Fall nicht und ist natürlich.
Alarmierend.
Ja so wie drei Leute verletzt noch Leute gestorben außer ich weiß garnicht.
Ich glaube dass sie alle nur Lebensgefahr waren sie keinen getötet hat außer sich selber.
Ja schlimm genug also ich meine können wir das Ganze Fass aufmachen mit Waffengewalt in den USA.
Das bringt man sich herzlich wenig aber was für ein interessanter Aspekt hierbei muss man so ganz aus der Ferne mit zugekniffenen Augen anschaut na ja.
Diese ganze Internet policy und wir ändern das mal heute von heute auf morgen.
Hat enorme Konsequenzen Ernte teilweise manchmal sich der Bewusstsein teilweise nicht.
Ja es ist unter Umständen schon so weit gediehen dass die Leute halt was ich darf einmal mit ihrem Leben abschließen und zu absolut unvorstellbar handhaken ausdrücken.
Also da gehört aber natürlich noch mehr zu als nur das von YouTube mit YouTube irgendwie mit der policy nicht zufrieden zu sein das ist aber.
Ja was sind ja auch so so Maßnahmen ja also ich will jetzt auch gar nicht sagen YouTube ist schuld oder so dass das ist nicht das was ich damit sagen will nur sie ändern hat sie ihre policies,
von heute auf morgen ohne viel Diskussion ist halt so weil es unsere Plattform so sind die Regeln wir machen die Regeln die du besitzt so.
Und das hat natürlich Konsequenzen so ein aber es gibt da jetzt keinerlei Regulativ ja so wie wenn jetzt hier.
Lahnung.
Also das wo hier heute gestreikt wird wenn sich die Bedingungen für die Einkommens Bedingungen für Arbeiter ändern ja wenn Entlassung anstehen oder Zahlung nicht mehr geleistet werden oder Steuern enorm erhöht werden irgendetwas was auf diesem Wirtschaftskreislauf,
eine nennenswerte Auswirkung hat die für manche vielleicht tragbar ist für manche ja egal ist für einzelne habe auch katastrophal sein kann.
Dann gibt es jetzt an dieser Stelle keinerlei Regulativ,
was ist dann halt so nah und klar kann man sagen na ja das ist ja das gehört ja YouTube und damit Google und das ist ja ihr eigenes Ding und ihre Plattform können sie ja machen was sie wollen,
stimmt natürlich nur mit dem Unterschied dass die Bedeutung dieser Plattform halt.
Deutlich über das was wir uns unter die unter der Macht eines einzelnen Unternehmens bisher haben vorstellen könnt hinaus,
ähnliche der Dimension hatte apple store,
von Apple bei Facebook haben wir ja nun schon ausführlich geredet auch wenn es da jetzt nicht so SERUM monetäre Sachen gibt aber es gibt eben auch sehr viele Plattform die im auch schon sehr klar definieren.
Wieso Geld zu verdienen ist und so na stell mal vor Amazon würde jetzt irgendwie sein sein sein bitte dein Partner Programm mit dem Beteiligung einstellen.
Du Amazon macht jedes Jahr also mit dem Beteiligung das einzustellen wäre natürlich das wäre richtig krass aber die ziehen auch jedes Jahr ihren Handelspartnern gegenüber die Daumenschrauben an.
Und das läuft im Prinzip also ich versuche die Geschichte jetzt mal so zu el also das so dass ich nicht erzähle von wem ist er läuft im Prinzip so dass sie.
Langer Verlagen oder Buchhändlern.
Im Prinzip einfach die neuen Preise diktieren die werden halt.
Genannt und das Gespräch läuft dann ihr wieso ja im nächsten Jahr muss das n Prozent günstiger sein.
Was ist bei euch nicht.
Und dann sagen sagen sagen die gegenüber ja nee das geht nicht wir haben ja auch Kosten und dann sagen die ja gut wenn das nicht geht ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
So
Kaufen wir das halt nicht.
Und das ist natürlich auch da hängt am anderen Ende Menschenleben na da muss es gibt Zeit irgendwo.
Begrenzt aber jetzt sind wir abgeschweift wenn demnächst bei Amazon einer rum ballert was ich im übrigen wie das Unternehmen sich verhält echt nicht,
unwahrscheinlich finden würde na also wie die ihre Mitarbeiter behandeln wie die ihre Geschäftspartner behandeln und so bei der Masse an Menschen leben die die.
Beeinflussen und beeinträchtigen ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt nicht so gering dass da auch mal jemand drunter ist der psychische Schwierigkeiten hat und keine andere.
Das hat sich jetzt schon ausrichten ich wollte ja eigentlich nur so darauf hinaus dass ich nur mal so klar macht was platform Abhängigkeit benutze deutet natürlich finden die Leute das toll dass es so einen Ort überhaupt erst gibt so wo man das denn überhaupt erst machen kann.
Und das konnte man auch nur deshalb machen weil es eben so groß geworden ist weil es Goto Medium geworden ist und weil das Interesse daran ebenso groß ist das eben andere,
Einkommensquellen dort erst erschlossen werden konnten immer noch als Google YouTube gekauft hat lang ist das jetzt her 2000.
Sowas am sicher alle gewundert haben.
Videos im Internet angucken Google damit.
Französische heute keiner mehr Stellen so ja und das ist halt den Weg den der sich gezeigt hat im Internet dass der sehr erfolgreich ist ja lass deine Plattform wachsen.
Versuche diesen kritischen Punkt zu überschreiten ab dem du vasi Platzhirsch bist.
Und dann wenn diese,
Rolle geschaffen wurde dann kannst du halt auch anfangen deine Regeln neu zu definieren kannst du auch dein ganzes Modell umstellen weil die Leute die dann halt irgendwann nicht mehr weglaufen weil sie nicht von dir weglaufen können.
Habe bei Facebook so gehabt das ist jetzt mit Amazon angedeutet ähnliches geht ja auch hier für.
Spendenplattform gezittert muss man einfach vorsichtig sein.
Das ärgerliche ist das heute diese Arten Plattform immer auf dem.
So ähnlich wie die GEMA da inselmodell landen wo ist eine ganze Reihe.
Kleinstbeträge an irgendjemand ausgehändigt also an jeden wird irgend so ein kleines Mittag ausgehändigt damit dieses Ziel verfolgen kann irgendwann bin ich auch ein großer YouTube-Star.
Wer hat aber den großen im Zweifelsfall werden halt gepostet Sonate zu ziehen damit YouTube wie ein Fernsehsender begreifen würde könnte man sagen die haben Riesenglück weil dieses gesamte Programm Entwicklung sparen können.
Konkurrieren quasi einfach alle darum bei ihnen Geld zu verdienen und ob die jetzt und ihnen wäre Bewerbung Herr anzuschaffen und völlig egal was die Leute gucken da sind YouTube nichts kostet das zu produzieren,
können Sie das alles halt vermarkten das heißt Sie müssen eigentlich so ein Sweet Spot finden das halt möglichst.
Viel dort geboten wird und ein paar cashcode dieses Handy wurde leider nicht mehr wo du nicht möchtest dass sie vor vor vor Publikum jammern dass du zu wenig Geld verdienen da sagst du dann dafür dass das bei denen auch läuft.
GEMA ist ja ähnlich na wie groß ist ja auch so ein umverteilungs Mechanismus von unten nach oben.
Häuser von der Schießerei zu geh mal gekommen.
Ja warum wohl.
Warum wollen ich bin wahrscheinlich wieder Schuld ne.
Milchkaffee.
Hast du noch welche unglaublichen Kurzmeldung.
Die Angeber denke ich.
Luis ist ein Mythos Kurzmeldungen kannst du eigentlich auch mal wirklich mal wegstecken Was gibt's für ihn nicht.
Ja gut du.
Ja ja ich bin schuld ich weiß schon nur weil ich interessante Aspekte in Diskussion.
Ja okay Kurzmeldung bei Google Drive werden p***** gelöscht was auf Zimmer.
Okay was war jetzt mal kurz.
Google gibt.
Insbesondere Sexworker und 6 Uhr Karin haben sich beschwert dass Ihre Videos.
Von ihrem Google Drive gelöscht wurden und das ist interessant zweier Hand erstens weil das heißt die gucken auf die Dateien und zweitens würde ich jetzt mal,
hypothetisch sagen wenn das freischaffende Sexworker oder Sexworkerin waren dann haben die unter Umständen,
selbst kreiertes Video Matrei in diesem Google Drive gab es nicht,
welches was unter Umständen die Urheberrechte verletzt oder was bei Facebook im Revenge porn Filter stehen könnte sondern so.
Eigenen selbstgemachten.
Qualitäts und das ist.
Stiegenwirt Tragwein.
Lotto-bremen.de Lachseier.
Ja ich glaube das.
So also die ihre Promo-Video zu wohl wird also bei dir Google Drive gelöscht und die Frage ist woher wusste Google dass Sie da sind.
Und ich vermute dass die.
Dass sie das automatisch erkennt das heißt aber das jetzt wirklich völlig wird spekuliert aber das wäre echt super geile das eure.
Eure Videos die ihr oder eure Materialien diese Google Drive height of div automatisch irgendwelchen Untersuchungen zugeführt werden und das ist jetzt echt langsam beängstigend.
Wenn auch nicht unerwartet.
Wenn auch nicht unerwartet auch davor haben wir andauernd gewarnt und jetzt ist es soweit kauft Festplatten.
Haben solche Sachen sind echt da denke ich mir wieder bin ich froh dass ich eigene Infrastrukturbetreiber.
Dass du deine hast du deine Wolke in deinem Schlafzimmer hast achso okay.
Nicht im Schlafzimmer nee nee ich sag nicht wo die steht sonst treten mir die Tür ein und hol dich da raus.
Ja Facebook Hallo sie an dann kommen wir zum endlich Tim endlich hier Finger an Soundboard wir kommen nämlich zu.
Den Terminen.
Am 26.05 im Babylon in Berlin findet LFP statt ich weiß es nicht genau.
Wir das schon mal erwähnt aber du wolltest doch mal drauf hinweisen der Vorverkauf wiederum findet am 26. April statt das ist ein Monat vorher die Nuss.
Genau einen Monat vorher pünktlich zum Inkrafttreten nein nicht zum Interpreten zum entscheiden über das bayerische Polizeigesetz.
Ja dann Mittwoch den 18.04.
Das ist vorher gibt's nächste Veranstaltung in der Galerie Sud in Kassel damit mich mal der Disco Jannis muss eingeführt,
das wird auch mal wieder Zeit ich habe sowas ja auch schon mal gemacht Daniel Westhoff.
Erläutert euch die Metaphysik des Chaos glaube als Werkzeug Chaos Inspiration.
Okkultismus der Weg zur Illumination na ja wenn er jetzt schon etwas verwirrt seid dann hat die beste Voraussetzung.
Im Anschluss gibt's die gemütliche Runde mit Kakao.
Dass das ist auf jeden Fall ein Feature.
Wir bleiben in Kassel und zwar vom 1 bis 3. Juni findet im dortigen flipdot dem Hacker space Kassel Quad Stadt.
3 Tage Workshops Vorträge Projekte anschauen also so einen Tag der offenen Tür im Hackerspace 1. bis 3. Juni beginnen jeweils 12 Uhr Ende wenn keiner mehr kann im flipdot in Kassel.
Ja und am 15. Juni bis zum 17. Juni 2018 findet die sieben bei Konferenz in Stuttgart Stadt und ich habe so das Gefühl die meisten davon aber ja auch angekündigt die nicht sehr fleißig im einreichen.
Die haben sich auch beim easterhegg wieder mich daran erinnert.
Sie schon es wird noch gesucht nach Vorträgen Diskussionsbeiträge und Workshops zu verschiedenen Themengebieten gesellschaftliche politische und technische Aspekte von Überwachung Demokratie und Geheimdienst Kontrolle.
Digitale Selbstverteidigung ist auch dabei wir haben einen Link zum TFP für euch.
Und vom 25 bis 26 August 2018 in Sankt Augustin in der Hochschule Rhein Sieg findet wieder die FrOSCon statt die findet auch seit vielen Jahren statt ne.
Oh ja ich habe keine Ahnung die wievielte das ist aber das ist jetzt schon für dich geht in die Jahrhunderte.
Das ist sie ist das ist eines der großen freertos Conventions in Deutschland ich höre von allen die da waren immer nur größtes Lob.
Ja und dann lass das noch liest im Oktober allerdings erst vom 22 bis 28.
Finde die privacy week in Wien Stadt im Volkskundemuseum und üblicherweise doch auch noch an vielen anderen Orten ich weiß es nicht so ganz genau auf jeden Fall da könnt ihr mal schauen privacy weg.at.
Hat auch noch den CRP offen und ich habe mich da auch schon beworben.
So gib mir doch mal jetzt nicht so kurz wie alle anderen Meldungen.
Welche welcher gerade schon angefangen habe auf Amazon zu landen,
in Berlin kommt es in letzter Zeit bei Amazon echt zu schwerwiegenden.
Lieferproblem und zwar dass Sachen irgendwo abgegeben werden niemand darüber Bescheid bekommt,
und ich dann Wochen später also von Nachbarn irgendwie, also vielleicht wieder kein Zettel im Briefkasten gehabt hier,
Nummer Paket oder so und dass ich auch festgestellt habe dass ich den Eindruck habe dass bestimmte Pakete nie bei mir angekommen sind.
Die ich eigentlich erwartet habe.
Insofern hört bitte noch mal genau hin bei denen Danksagung und wenn da irgendwas war oder wenn ihr Fehlermeldung habt oder so meldet euch doch mal bei mir und,
ich bin da sowieso gut wenn ihr euch irgendwie mal kurz bei mir meldet weil ich jetzt gerade wieder einer nicht in einer mir unbekannten Person sehr herzlich danken muss.
Also liebe unbekannte Person du erkennst dich daran dass du deinen Namen noch nicht gehört hast und auch jetzt nicht höher ist vielen Dank.
Und ansonsten danke an Franz Josef Lukas mag noch mal Christoph und Christian ihr habt mir sehr große Freude bereitet.
Und wir lagen vor allem mit allen die wieder hier ein dreiviertel Stunde mit uns ausgehalten haben und sich auch Freund und geplanten Lachflashs nicht aus der Spur bringen lassen.
Wasner.
Ich denke schon.
Wir wären jetzt mal wieder die wöchentliche Produktion aufnehmen weil wir müssen ja mit unserer Zellen genau hinkommen zur 256 Ameland die Veranstaltung schon erwähnt.
26556.
Das ist doch die Veranstaltung wo ein Monat vorher der Verkauf beginnt.
Genau einen Monat vorher am 25.04 64.
I am 26 habe ich 26.05 bisher die Veranstalter.
Aber am 25.04 bist da schon versuchen eure Box zu schreiben um die Tickets zu scorn.
Warte wird lasst euch bis bald.
Ciao ciao und vielen Dank.